that emotional video there shows a
california man hugging his daughters and
sobbing as he was reunited with them
after spending nearly eight years in
prison corvain cooper was sentenced
to life in prison for nonviolent
marijuana charges back in 2014
but in his final hours in office
president trump granted him
and 142 other people clemency
national correspondent rica duncan spoke
with cooper in his first interview
since his release i'm serving a life
sentence for
marijuana money lines and tax invasions
for non-violent crime
that's the voice of corvain cooper from
a maximum security prison
the 41 year old was featured in the 2020
b-e-t
documentary smoke marijuana and black
america
this is corvain cooper now free at home
finally able to hug his 15 and 11 year
old daughters
[Music]
i seen my daughters and i finally got to
tell them you know i'm sorry
your dad sorry i chose the wrong road
and
trying to provide for you guys and it
took me away from you guys sorry for
missing
everything that i've missed it wasn't
just you that was serving time
your family served this time your
daughter served this time
the pain that i have caused on
my kids and on my dad and on my mom
and all my family and all my loved ones
and the pain that i caused on myself
it's been a long eight years for cooper
and his family when he was arrested in
2013
cooper says he hadn't sold marijuana in
at least four years
i had a clothing store that uh it was
like a boutique
that was called fc clothing after my
kids got let me clear
i had their he was convicted for his
involvement in trafficking marijuana
from california to north carolina
and sentenced under the now widely
criticized 1994 federal crime bills
three strikes rule
because cooper had two previous
nonviolent convictions
he received life without parole for his
third conviction
those two previous convictions were
later vacated
i'm watching rapists get out
and my brother was in prison facing life
without the possibility of parole
things have changed you know what i mean
and he's not there
all because of marijuana and then it's
legal here
so it makes it even worse change came to
california when cannabis was legalized
in 2017.
my kids have to roll by every day by
living in california
and they have to see more dispensaries
than they can even seen with the stores
the cloning store that i built from the
ground up with my
kids based on it had all events and
everything finally to try to make my
dream come true
and turn this dispensary to change
the clothing store to a weed store while
the nation has been decriminalizing
marijuana possession
and its use over the last decade relief
for cooper didn't come until the last
day of donald trump's presidency
when he granted cooper and at least 11
others like him
clemency so i'm in a cell for about an
hour
and then they come to the door and say
pack it up you got five minutes to get
out of here
you just gotta immediately release and i
just break wow just like that
just like that i made my first call and
i called my mom
and she said i'm crying
uncontrollably but she says where are
you crying for ivanka trump called me at
12
30 and said that you that you're coming
home a homecoming for a father
trying to make up for what he missed
with his daughters clear in scotland
it's like to have my dad home it's like
a relief like
it's like i was when he was in jail like
i was missing a part of him
it's like a piece of
a piece of me is back it was like
memories lost like i would see my
friends
have their dad there and never pick him
up and i didn't have that memory with my
dad
a dad determined to set an example by
growing a message of hope
how do you save someone like yourself at
that time
first thing i'm going to tell them is
they get to see the results they get to
see what actually happened
to me i got a life sentence i'm going to
show them the stuff
that they're chasing it's all fool's
gold
cooper started a website selling
clothing
and also advocating for companies that
legally sell
marijuana he said that the bet
documentary smoke marijuana in black
america was
pivotal in raising awareness about his
story
and many others and we should note that
bet is a division
of viacom cbs tony it's a powerful story
drika thank you very much what i think
people really need to take away from
this is that the issue is mandatory
minimum sentences yes
it ties the judge's hands in my own case
my own father as i've talked about
before
sold tons of marijuana but did so just
before the mandatory minimum so when he
got caught
also by the feds he got less than three
years not life
yeah that's the difference it judges it
shows the inequities that's why that
documentary is very powerful
it it'll have you scratching your head
and screaming at the same time like how
is this pos especially when you're
stories like your dad
judges don't want to look at the judges
want to be able to look at a case and
make a decision based on the facts
before them
mandatory minimums tie judges hands and
that's what needs to be looked at that's
absurd but
i'm so you're so happy for scotland and
clear yes because it tied hands for a
lot of
men of color and there are more and
there are more there are more it's not
over now